[Music]
why didn't you guys help fight thanos
or any war all the other terrible things
throughout history
we were instructed not to interfere in
any human conflicts unless deviants are
involved
by who
eternals explores the very creation of
the marvel universe itself
the film also deals very much with the
aftermath of avengers 4 and the state
the world is in
five of the eternals are more of the
thinkers
and the other five are the stronger
fighters
the eternals are these remarkably
superpowered characters
but also a dysfunctional family unit
this is what the end of the world looks
like at least we have front row seats
you know what's never saved the planet
you're sarcasm the person to bring that
together was academy award winner chloe
jaw
we go on these emotional journeys with
these eternals
to figure out who they are and what it
means to be human
her vision
is so clear
it's not the typical place it's not the
typical shots it's not the typical cast
everybody looks different everybody
sounds different
[Music]
a lot of people are gonna see themselves
as superheroes for the first time
really is an epic global film the scope
and the scale of it is huge
it's so exciting to be part of something
that really feels new
the impact that eternals will have on
the mcu will be nothing less than
redefining the cinematic universe
entirely
[Music]
you